dating and being in a relationship are
two entirely different things now some
of you are probably saying now they're
not they're the same I've been dating my
girlfriend for the past two years wrong
have used the word girlfriend that
implies exclusivity and therefore you're
in a relationship simply put dating is a
verb a relationship is a noun a verb is
an action while a noun is a thing over
time and after enough action and if you
decide not to pull the plug this will
eventually turn into a thing when you've
been in a noun long enough you
eventually stopped having verbs and all
of a sudden she's nitpicking your
grammar all the time reminding you to
never end your sentences and
prepositions and it becomes very evident
who the pronoun is then you find out her
nouns are irregular before you know you
got a couple of constants and vowels
running around then you start thinking
back on the past participle and you're
checking out every sweet little
adjective and adverb that walks by and
you're thinking to yourself this isn't
how I imagined my paragraph turning out
that's a relationship completely
different than dating point John unlike
a relationship when you're dating you
pretty much have zero obligations other
than showing up on time at the greet
upon time good a sworn we said eight
o'clock Jessica not eight 37 and by no
means is there any sort of requirement
to meet the other parties friends
coworkers and certainly not their
parents that's insane
I mean your parents we've been on three
dates hello Jessica's father can I call
you Bill I'm gonna call you bill bill I
did things your daughter last night you
couldn't even imagine also your wife's
got a pretty sweet little ass I don't
want to say all this because I don't
have to respect you because we're only
dating see when you're dating you're not
bound by anything it's kind of like
you've signed a nondisclosure agreement
with yourself and your date is the third
party you wish to restrict certain
information with that being said it's
important that you know that your date
is probably signed his/her own
non-disclosure agreements so they don't
owe you any explanations either you're
just two people sharing dinner and
bodily fluids potentially with multiple
parties and you can bend the truth where
you can't in a relationship I don't know
what you're talking about I was at home
all night last night at one point too
true those sick all right I'm deathly
ill literally dying cuz I'm just
coughing and hacking that's why I
couldn't respond any or text I wanted to
I saw my phone there I'm like oh but I
didn't see it because I was asleep in a
bed somewhere at home
it's a big house and luckily I had tons
of medicine last night tons of medicine
I've mix in medicine so now I'm better
relationship is a lot of work and dating
there's a lot of effort still up for
debate if either is worth all the energy
hey guys thanks for watching be sure to
follow on social and like favor and
share this video right now
[Music]